You put this out there every single day.
Anyone has access to it.
And they can learn a bucket load of
information about you.
What is it?
Hey peeeeps. Trace here for Dnews.
Any idea what I'm talking about? I'll give
you a hint.
It has nothing to do with social media but
you do it every day.
Still no guesses?
It's pee.
Urine. Piss. Mixture it.
Yeah its pee, and it is dead
useful.
You're probably wondering what I can
find out from your urine.
Science has tools to find out what drugs you
are taking,
what you've eaten,
the health of your excretory system, whether
you're pregnant and crap ton
of other the things that you likely already
heard about.
We wouldn't be Dnews if we only told you the
stuff that you already knew.
So how about this: I could take your
urine and make brain cells.
Urine contains water soluble waste that
your body doesn't need. It's filtered through
the kidneys and stored in the bladder
until you get rid of it.
Reprogramming skin cells that make their
way into this waste, Chinese scientists created
brain cells.
You're literally pissing away your brain cells.
Using these cells scientists
believe we can turn little bits from our own
pee
into our own stem cells and use them to
cure diseases like Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's.
Yeah from pee.
Not good enough?
Okay
How about cancer?
Scientists in the UK created
an electronic nose that can tell if you have
bladder cancer with a single sniff of your
urine.
Usually a cystoscopy has to be performed to
check the bladder
from the inside so it has to go
[gulp]
You know what, just look it up. It's awful.
This is way better.
The odoreader has a 100 percent accuracy
at identifying bladder cancer in a thirty
minute window.
That's pretty great.
And if you're not worried about cancer, how
about something more
practical?
Students in Nigeria used urine to
create hydrogen power.
And some scientists in the UK turn
similar technology into a pee-powered
cell phone charger.
Both work by feeding pizzle to microbes
which turn the compound and
excrements into small amounts of energy.
And it's not just phones and lights.
NASA was looking at this technology to
hydrazine as a propellant that can be used
in rocket fuel.
And using micro organisms some Dutch
scientist were able to create hydrazine
from the ammonia in urine.
Ammonia is what gives your pizzle that acrid
smell.
Unfortunately the hydrazine was created
in such small quantities that NASA lost
interest.
If you're more into the practical
fun of urine. You know, writing writing your
name in the snow.
Or whatever. Then you should check out
Captive Media, a London-based company, that
uses your stream to power video games.
You can create art, which is
shareable via email thank goodness,
navigate ski slopes and even play trivia
games.
Aside from games, some Singaporean urinal
cakes can
identify how drunk you are
by testing biomarkers in your tinkle.
Paired with RFID tags, these unusual
urinals can alert valet workers that
certain drivers might be too
drunk to drive home.
Are you gonna look at your pee a little
differently now?
Is this gross science or just great stuff?
Share your thoughts with us and hey, don't
forget to flush.